a lot of the business i learned from
from
rap and from from um wrestling was
self-promotion about making yourself
seem like a big deal
that if if you made yourself seem like a
big deal
no one's going to believe you are a big
deal until you do and so
a lot of my like i would post about my
shows i would post about what's going on
even if they were half full
i would just take pictures i would post
about them
because i was like you want to be a part
of this people the half full room that
was here
they loved it you should be here they
are the cool people
and then a lot of it was like selling
t-shirts and selling posters
like when i started doing that a lot of
it was kind of looked down upon that it
was corny that it was hacky that it was
that's what rogue comics do
but i knew every time i went to a
wrestling show
every time i went to a rap show i wanted
to leave with that
artist's t-shirt because i wanted to
support them because i wanted to
i thought it was cool if i came back
with a currency shirt or a
devin the dude shirt or whatever like
and i thought it was weird that comics
didn't
seem look at it like that and so i
wanted i got into merge more i got into
self-promotion more and i got into
making like little commercials for my
[ __ ] for my runs for my um tour um
looked at the job and i i understood
that it wasn't like it wasn't always
improv you know it wasn't coming up with
a new joke every time you went on stage
you might
work on some wording you might change
things up but a lot of times
you know you're working on your act over
and over and over again
and so i decided that if i wanted if i
had to say the same things over and over
again that i wanted to talk about things
i love
and i want to talk about things that
made me happy not things that
um i didn't want to give power to the
things that i hated
in in comedy we a lot of us get this
mindset of like oh we're we're
pure artists we just want to do stand up
like so many
my friends i'd even talk to and they'd
be like why do you want to do voice
acting why
you want to do like like stand up is the
purity and as
i think if anyone sees right now
diversifying your portfolio is a [ __ ]
god because there's no stage for you to
hit right now
but however i'm still getting checks
from trolls
[Laughter]
but i don't either here nor there
oh and in my writing i always
stopped anytime i if the word because
came into my my sentence i was like oh
i've talked too much
and you know if i have to get into where
i'm explaining it where i'm like
because of this then i've not explained
well
you know like i should be able to
explain it without getting into a
secondary
because so i started looking at that and
being like
okay if that's in here then i need to
find a way to sharpen it if there's a
curse word in here
can it be replaced i learned a lot of
that from from from jp buck
actually who is the producer for conan
and
the first time i worked with him like a
lot of my stuff had much more curse
words in it
and he was just like well what if you
did this what if you did that what if
you you know what if this is a funnier
way of saying it
and and i i was like wow like you
a lot of times cursing and being dirty
is a way of being lazy
and so if i find a way to get the same
idea across with a funnier word or a
made-up word
even then that was more fun than just
saying [ __ ] or [ __ ] now sometimes i need
if the punch line is
[ __ ] you or that like i don't i don't
believe in going oh frick you
or use you know son of a bee i don't
believe in that
like if you if the curse word is there
it needs to be there
and and that's another that's one of my
truest advice
that i could give is that if something
embarrasses me
if i feel a tinge of like ooh i don't
i don't know if i want to talk about
that i lean into it and then i write
about it
because that has always proven
to pull the best material for me um and
the beginning of that was doing jokes
about my son having autism i didn't want
to do those jokes
i thought they made me sad a little bit
talking about it
and i didn't want people to think i was
making fun of my son
i didn't want to think that people think
i was making fun of autism
um i i mean i remember the one the first
the first times i told him another comic
came up to me like oh i like those jokes
about your [ __ ] kid
and i was like you don't get what i'm
doing at all
oh my gosh
wow that's gold though if something
embarrasses me i lean into it
wow if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing today